what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like we have a release date
update for Avengers Secret Wars and not
going to lie it's kind of disappointing
however if you take a look at everything
that Marvel Studios has planned
hopefully it won't seem like that long
of a wait now unfortunately a lot has
happened to put not only Marvel Studios
and Disney behind but a lot of other
Studios as well because of the actor and
writer strikes plus not to mention
Marvel Studios and Disney are Chang in
up their strategy when it comes to
Disney plus content and we haven't heard
of Marvel Studios wanting to cancel any
of these projects yet and we do know
that they have a lot planned for Disney
plus so if they're not going to cancel
any and they're going to space them
further out that of course is going to
extend Marvel Phase 5 and Marvel Phase 6
to later dates there's a lot of reasons
why this could have changed but
unfortunately for us it looks like the
movie has been pushed back a few years
from its original release date when
Marvel Studios at s Diego Comic-Con in
2022 announced Phase 5 and Phase 6 they
had Avengers Secret Wars coming out on
November 7th
2025 that was the original release date
they have moved it back since and as far
as we were concerned it was supposed to
come out on May 7th of
2027 however due to a recent Insider
report we believe that it may be later
than that according to Alex P at the
cosmic circus we might not be getting
Avengers Secret Wars until 2028 he
stated in a tweet last thing for you
guys they still need more time to cook
hearing 2028 at the earliest and he
posted a picture of the logo for
Avengers Secret Wars now Alex P has a
really good track record when it comes
to inside Scoops plus like I mentioned
there have been a lot of delays recently
so it looks like unfortunately this is
probably the case for Avengers Secret
Wars we're probably not going to get it
till 2028 hopefully things change and it
could come out sooner but if they're
going to take more time to make it
better to try to make it better than
Avengers Infinity war and Avengers
endgame then that makes it kind of okay
that they are taking so long however
like I mentioned the other reason they
are taking so long is because they have
so many other amazing projects coming
out that are actually going to kick off
Secret Wars you see Secret Wars was a
huge event in the comics both secret War
Stories are huge and when this was first
announced a lot of fans were really
really concerned about only one movie
being able to handle the story of Secret
Wars but it doesn't look like that's the
cas case it looks like Marvel Studios is
beginning secret wars with other
projects and this makes a ton of sense
in the MCU Secret Wars isn't just going
to be one movie it's going to be many
different movies that make up the event
of Secret Wars itself and the final
movie the ending to it all is going to
be the actual film titled Avengers
Secret Wars but we know that it's going
to start way sooner than that and there
are so many projects to be excited for
that we'll go over right now and a
reminder if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news and if you subscribe
and leave a comment you're entered for
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 and some other items the
winner picks one item and we pick a
winner at the end of each month so as
far as what is coming from Marvel
Studios that is going to be a part of
the overall secret War storyline because
not all of it will not all of the
content coming from Marvel is going to
directly set up or connect to Secret
Wars but there are some massive projects
that are going to directly be a part of
this massive story and it starts with
Loki season 2 now we don't really need
to spend too much time on this most of
us know a lot about what is going to
happen in Loki season 2 because we
watched Loki season 1 Loki knows that he
who remains was behind the TVA and now a
lot of other variants essentially
infinite amount of variants of Kang are
set free and a multiversal war is coming
unless he can stop Kang so obviously
this connects in a super huge way and
this really is going to truly kick off
Secret Wars then we have the Marvels and
I know a lot of people don't think this
is going to connect too much but it is
from what we've heard in the Marvels we
are actually going to see an incursion
plus not to mention the Bengals one that
Kamala Khan has and the other darb Ben
has are presumed King Technology and
could even be from Another Universe and
perhaps the Bengals are why an incursion
is happening in the first place but
that's going to connect to the overall
story of Secret Wars as well and then
we're going to really really dive into
it a lot more with Doctor Strange 3
Doctor Strange 2 already tackled
incursions they explained what they are
and explained and showed us that some of
already happened and Doctor Strange 3 is
going to go even further with it because
Doctor Strange 2 dealt with incursions
that have already happened but Doctor
Strange 3 will deal with incursions that
are currently happening and it just so
happens to be that doctor strange
himself has caused one or many of them
we know that doctor strange as a
character not just the single doctor
strange that we know from our main
universe but multiple doctor Stranges
from other universes as well all the
variants could be a common cause that
the Multiverse is collapsing that and
you know King but apparently Doctor
Strange 3 is going to touch on a topic
that was mildly touched on in Doctor
Strange 2 the thought of Dr Strange
being the biggest threat to the
Multiverse him and Kang that is
apparently what Doctor Strange 3 is
supposed to be about and I'm really
excited to see where they take it then
we have a Scarlet Witch Solo movie now
we're not 100% sure what exactly this
movie is going to be about however most
people assume that she's going to have a
decent role to play in the story of
Avengers Secret Wars she read the entire
dark and after all she is the most
powerful being in our universe so far
that we know of so we assume she's going
to play a major role another person or
team that we assume is going to play an
insane role in secret Wars is the
Fantastic Four and Reed Richards and
actually based off what we've heard so
far Marvel is going to be really
changing things up with the Fantastic 4
we'll talk about this huge news in just
a bit but first a big thank you to
DraftKings for sponsoring this video
DraftKings rain makers football is back
for its second season and it's bigger
and better than ever before if you head
to draftkings.com AIO you can sign up to
play rain makers today using Code Cosmic
for your share of over $30 million in
prizes this football season and this
week new customers can claim their first
pack of digital players cards for free
to get started playing rain makers
football is simple each DraftKings
digital card represents an athlete and
scores points based on their real world
performance draft them into weekly
contest for your shot at a share of $30
million in prizes and one of the best
parts is rain makers contests require no
fee to join as long as you have enough
cards to complete a lineup rip packs
build your collection and earn big
rewards so wondering how to get started
new customers can visit draftkings.com
auday and use promo code Cosmic to claim
a free starter pack again only at
draftkings.com Audi code Cosmic now
what's crazy is that the recent news
that we've heard about the Fantastic 4
film is that this movie might not only
take place back in the 1960s but it also
could take place in an entirely
different Universe than our main MCU
which our Avengers are in but this makes
sense because Secret Wars is about the
Multiverse it's not just one universe
but a lot of different universes so
showing us the point of view from
Another Universe is a really great idea
and a great twist that will make
everything really really exciting and
it'll be fresh and it'll be new and at
the same time it raises a lot of
exciting questions like at the end of
Avengers Secret Wars if the Fantastic
Four are from Another Universe will they
be sent back to that Universe at the end
or will they remain in our universe
because we know the Fantastic 4 is going
to be around for a lot more than just
one movie so we assume they'll end up in
our universe somehow but we don't know
and that's what makes it exciting and
then of course we have Avengers the Kang
Dynasty all the movies leading up to
Kang Dynasty are still a part of the
overall plot of Avengers Secret Wars but
Kang Dynasty is basically where
everything hits the fan this is where
all of the events that have been
happening separately come together for
one huge event and that event of course
is to take on King the Conqueror but as
we know the Avengers aren't going to win
this battle and the Multiverse is going
to essentially be destroyed that's why
the movie Avengers Secret Wars comes
after and what's actually going to
really contribute to Avengers King
Dynasty is Deadpool 3 based off of what
we've heard so far Deadpool 3 is
essentially going to be Avengers
Infinity War and what I mean by that is
Deadpool 3 is going to be its own film
but the events that take place in the
movie are going to directly set up Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars they will lead
right into these other two movies and
what we've heard so far about Deadpool 3
is that we are actually going to see a
lot of incursions happen and we'll see
people and heroes from other universes a
lot of other universes be taken and put
into one single universe so we'll have a
universe where a lot of different Heroes
come from other universes to be a part
of we've heard that the TVA are the
people that are supposedly taking these
Heroes and putting them in one universe
and also villains as well the question
is why are they doing that are they
saving them are they putting them there
for a certain purpose could Kang
possibly be behind it we're unsure but
we do know that after Deadpool 3 and
after the King Dynasty the Multiverse is
essentially going to start falling apart
and from there there are going to be
movies in between the two Avengers films
movies like Shang Chi 2 that will also
invol the 10 Rings which should be King
Technology as well and then we could get
more movies that possibly take place in
other universes and this would make a
lot of sense as the Multiverse is
essentially being destroyed and
incursions are happening everywhere we
get movies that take place in other
universes to give us their perspective
because they're going to take the heroes
from a lot of different universes and
bring them all into one and that is what
Avengers Secret Wars is going to be and
again A lot of people are still kind of
worried that one movie might not be big
enough or long enough to handle this
gigantic story but that is exactly why
Secret Wars really is a culmination of a
lot of different films and shows
happening within phase five and phase
six which is a really great approach
which should make us all feel a little
bit more at ease but on top of that we
have gotten some reports that Avengers
Secret Wars might be split into two
different parts a part one and a part
two and this would make a lot of sense
considering how much is going into
Secret Wars and how intricate the
details of the movie are going to
actually be I wouldn't mind at all them
taking their time to tell the story to
get the story right and them doing that
by splitting the movie in two especially
if you consider everything that is going
to happen beforehand I would rather them
take their time and hopefully we won't
have to wait till 2028 but as we've
shown you in this video there are a lot
of awesome projects coming out
beforehand that can keep us occupied
that will still be a part of Secret Wars
that will kick off the secret War
storyline but go ahead and let us know
your thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below and let us know if
you would like Avengers Secret Wars to
be split into a part one and a part two
leave your comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest MCU news of course you can follow
us on Instagram and Twitter as well and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof